the term higher consciousness is often
used by spiritually minded people to
describe important but hard to reach
mental states Hindu sages Christian
monks and Buddhist ascetics all speak of
reaching moments of higher consciousness
through meditation or chanting fasting
or pilgrimages unfortunately the way in
which these spiritual people discuss
their states of higher consciousness has
a tendency to put a lot of secular types
on edge it can also maddening leave a
wishy-washy touchy-feely and for want of
a better word annoying what on earth do
these gurus really mean we deeply
sympathise with such frustrations not
being by nature particularly attracted
to the ineffable or the mysterious
however it seems that the idea of higher
consciousness is in fact a very
interesting one which has nothing
inherently to do with spirituality and
can be defined simply enough in strictly
rational and secular terms this is how
we see it as human beings we spend most
of our lives functioning in states of
lower consciousness where what were
principally concerned with is ourselves
our survival and our own success
narrowly defined ordinary life rewards
practical on introspective
self-justifying outlooks through the
hallmarks of lower consciousness
neuroscientists speak of a lower part of
the brain they call the reptilian mind
and tell us that under its sway we
strike back when we hit blame others
quell any stray questions that lack
immediate relevance fail to free
associate and stick closely to a
flattering image of who we are and where
we're headed however at rare moments
when there are no threats or demands
upon us perhaps late at night or early
in the morning when our bodies and
passions are comfortable and quiescent
we have the privilege of being able to
access the higher mind what
neuroscientists call uh neocortex the
seat of imagination empathy and
impartial judgment we loosen our hold on
our own egos and ascend to a less biased
and more universal perspective casting
off a little of the customer
anxious self-justification and brittle
pride in such States the mind moves
beyond its particular self interests and
cravings we start to think of other
people in a more imaginative way rather
than criticize an attack we're free to
imagine their behavior being driven by
pressures derived from their own
primitive Minds which they're generally
in no position to tell us about that
temper or viciousness are we now see
symptoms of hurt rather than of evil
it's an astonishing gradual evolution to
develop the ability to explain others
actions by their distress rather than
simply in terms of how it effects us we
perceive that the appropriate response
to humanity is not fear cynicism or
aggression but always when we can manage
it love at such moments the world
reveals itself was quite different a
place of suffering and misguided effort
full of people's striving to be heard
and lashing out against others but also
a place of tenderness in long butene
touchy vulnerability fitting responses
universal sympathy and kindness one's
own life feels less precious one can
contemplate being no longer present if
tranquility once interests to put aside
and one may imaginatively fuse with
transient or natural things trees the
wind a moth clouds or waves breaking on
the shore from this point of view status
is nothing possessions don't matter
grievances lose their urgency if certain
people could encounter us at this point
they might be amazed at our
transformation and in our newfound
generosity and empathy States of higher
consciousness are of course desperately
short-lived
we shouldn't in any case aspire to make
them permanent because they don't sit so
well with the many important practical
tasks we all need to attend to but we
should make the most of them when they
do arise and harvest their insights for
when we require them most higher
consciousness is a huge triumph over the
primitive mind which cannot envisage any
such possibilities ideally we'd be a
little more alive to the advantages of
this higher mind and strive to make a
oceanic experiences somewhat less random
and
less clothes in unnecessary mystery